okay joining us now the newest member of
the top 10 all-time nfl rushers in
league history fresh off of 166 yards
from scrimmage on sunday and his debut
for washington he is the great adrian
peterson adrian how are you buddy i'm
great i'm great how you doing brother
hey i'm doing great then again i didn't
i didn't carry the ball and touch it 28
times on on sunday how you feeling two
days removed from that performance
i'm feeling pretty good man you know uh
monday i woke up and it was a little
stiff you know which i expected that um
a little sore but uh i'm feeling pretty
good today feeling really rejuvenated
are you at the point where you like that
feeling on monday because you missed
that feeling
uh yeah you know i was talking to my
wife earlier and i was like yeah man i
haven't felt like this in a in a long
time you know uh well yesterday when i
was speaking to her i was like hey i
feel like that a long time man but it
feels good you know uh it kind of just
especially for the running back position
kind of beats your body up and and give
you that extra layer of protection that
you need you know once your body kind of
once your body goes through that that
trauma it goes through after playing a
football game um only thing it does is
just get you
you know those layers that hardened and
ready to ready to take on the next game
how much harder was it for you to get
ready to do that given that you arrived
so late in the process to sign with
washington
um
you know it took it took a little time
because
playing football it's a totally
different ball game especially when you
get out there and you're playing live
action you know football there's nothing
that you could do
to uh you know to mimic playing on in
the nfl you know so you know having
three weeks under my belt helped out a
lot and i trained really hard to prepare
to be ready to come in and and make an
impact as soon as possible
um
but you know after game one i i felt
good i felt good i know that i'll i'll
just become stronger as the weeks
continue to roll to roll around
and adrian how long until you think
you'll have full mastery of the jay
gruden playbook
i'm picking it up uh well i'm picking it
up well you know i think here
here soon i'll pretty have you know
pretty much have a good grips of
everything they're asking us to do which
right now um you know i'm right in the
in the meat of it
as well so there's some things i need to
fine-tune and and
you know
make become first nature
and uh and out and i'll be
right on track
what's the hardest part of learning that
is it terminology is it the play designs
is it studying the film to see what
you're supposed to do what's the hardest
aspect of of getting yourself up to
speed with that new offense
i would say the terminology is always a
big thing um
and because it can be something as
simple as a swing route you know a swing
route can be
um you know you're back there in the eye
formation a single you know single back
formation
you're swinging out to the right or
you're in a gun formation and you're
just running like a wide route to the
right and then another offense that
screen route can be an actual screen
route where you're selling the flat and
you're wrapping it up you know so it's
like small things like that with
terminology with different teams that
you go to
that uh when you're when you're familiar
with okay a swing route just kind of
being like a wide
then you know it's like first nation
when you hear it you kind of lock into
doing to doing that so it's like
correcting those small things and that's
just like small things within the office
terminology
that could that can kind of you know be
a struggle but uh so i'll say that and
then also
you know having the type of offensive
line that i have
um just being more of a patient runner
you know because these guys are they got
a heck of a offensive line coach
and he does a great job with those guys
in half for the past couple of years
but really having these guys up front
that create hoes like these guys are big
athletic they can run
so having that trust being in sync with
those guys and letting those plays
develop more
um is something that i'm working on as
well because normally i'm just like bam
100 miles per hour you know taking the
last couple situations i've been in
where the offensive line you know i
really couldn't count on them actually
doing their job um with these guys you
know nine times out of ten um you know
they're going to get their job done so
being patient and trusting um the scheme
and where the ball is supposed to hit is
something that i'm working on as well
that has got to be so hard though you've
been in the league since 2007 to change
your instinct the moment you get the
ball and force yourself to slow down and
wait for the hole to develop i mean how
do you how do you adjust that process of
thinking because i think when you get in
those moments and you get the ball you
don't have time to consciously think you
just react
yeah you know um i'm kind of
based on this last game i felt like i
was kind of 50 50. so i was able to
um kind of bounce it out with me being
slow up top like with my footwork
you know and consciously
being slow you know up top and then
letting things develop and then there's
a certain place where i have to be a
little faster um but
you know i've been playing this game for
a long time so making that type of
adjustment isn't really hard you know um
it's the end of me it rings in my mind
till this day he always told me
slow too
fast through you know and even though i
haven't actually lived
live to do it that way for 12 years i
find myself kind of going back to that
to uh to help them slow down
so uh
yeah you know just this with more time
and reps that we are able to accomplish
and practice and stuff
um things are just get in line alignment
even more
hey adrian you've been hearing a lot of
voices other than your own in your head
recently the critics out there the
naysayers and you know going into week
one it was adrian peterson can't do it
anymore and you prove that you can and
now the the message is going to be he
can't stay healthy he can't keep doing
it he can't put these games together
he's eventually going to get injured how
do you react when you hear that kind of
talk
you know it is what it is if it's not
one thing then you know it's another you
know if it's not one thing it's another
how many guys went down this week and we
went
you know like it's a lot of guys that
this is football this is a physical
physical sport in their physical game so
there's certain things that you you just
can't control you know uh so when i hear
when i hear people say things like that
it's like okay well now you can go on to
the next thing since obviously you know
the explosion the the vision the speed
and the burst and everything else that
you claimed that wasn't there you know
it was put on display and it's it's
still there clearly without a doubt and
you know you compare to
you know other banks around the league
that you watch week one
you know um
it just didn't look bad at all you know
so
uh it doesn't it wouldn't surprise me
that people would go to the next thing
because that's what people normally do
once they fail at one thing they go on
to the next and see how else
what other way they can try to tear
someone down you know but me i'm just
gonna focus on things that i can control
um keep getting better each week
and uh you know keep winning keep keep
wearing ball games
and adrian the other thing they like to
say is you're not a good receiver i see
uh 70 yards receiving including a 52
yard or the third longest of your career
how do you like getting a pass in your
hands like that and being able to show
people that number one you can catch it
number two you can do something with it
after you get it
i love it you know it gives me the
opportunity to catch the ball and you
know receive the ball out in space
you know and uh you know with the
ability god has left me with i'm able to
make some things happen
um when the ball is in my hand out you
know in space you know so
um you know this this whole notion that
hey you can't catch the ball it's crazy
you know
it it had i i remember seeing um
um
i was looking at one of my pictures and
they were like oh man they they ate
the redskins have um improved adrian
peterson pat i mean catching skills it's
like
50 years old you know
i haven't been in
a position to be out there and like
catch the ball you know and this is a
national football league you got players
like chris thomas thompson who's
he's a
a nightmare you know he's a match-up
nightmare for a linebacker you know like
you know smaller guy quick you know good
receiver guys like alvin kamar like he's
like this is a national football league
just you're getting the best talent in
the world you know so when you have a
guy that can pound the ball
and you have a guy that can you know
catch it and run routes
just a little better
you know or it might be uh leaps and
bounds better um that doesn't mean that
that guy the second or third guy can't
do the same thing you know and i think
that's where a lot of people kind of get
lost because
uh you know when you when you're in that
position you know mark ingram and alvin
kamari when you're in that position
you're gonna have alvin out there more
you know mark can do the same thing you
know he's getting from outside you know
not as chris but he can run around and
catch the ball as well but guess what
he's not gonna do it as much because
they got album come on
so when you understand that you know
he's just whatever you let people say
what they have to say
and uh you know it goes to show the
knowledge of football that they really
have
you mentioned mark ingram and alvin
kamara and i know it's one week at a
time and i know you're focused on the
cults but i see week five monday night
football i see the saints a trip to new
orleans but and we all know what
happened last year it just didn't work
out and and they moved you on to arizona
but
uh do you have a little extra in mind
for when you get a chance to show the
saints what uh what you could have done
if they had kept you around
you know it won't i'm not going to be
out of box or anything like that you
know i'm going to stay within our scheme
and i'm gonna go out there and do what i
do anytime i step on the field let's
give 110 percent you know so
with that i'll i just let the chips fall
where they make what they may you know
and you know if anything
um you know i guess they'll be able to
look back and be like hey well and i
guess we could have did this or could
have worked that out or just that
another but ultimately you know they
have you know two great backs down there
that that's getting the job done within
their system you know um i'm just gonna
continue to do what i can do and you
know
just show that i got it you know like
it's not a surprise to me that i went
out and had type of games actually i was
a little uh
disappointed uh in and my ground attack
you know
um but
you know i'm just gonna continue to do
what i do you know i've been blessed so
i'm gonna go out there and continue to
play and look too far where they may and
uh
that's gonna end up being a big game
against new orleans monday night then so
be it
when you see that that joe mixon from
the bengals had 95 yards on the ground
against the colts how how much does that
excite you for an opportunity to go out
and do the same or more this coming
weekend against indy
you know um we got a lot of respect for
joe mixon who's the guy that i've got
mentored and you know we keep in contact
as well
but you know teams they um i'm sure
they'll come in and have the the same
approach stop the run i'm sure
that was their focus
wanting to uh playing cincinnati you
know and uh you got different matchups
um as well so you gotta play all that um
you know you know to factor all that in
as well
um but you know
it's clear that the washington redskins
we're going to establish the run game so
it's not a secret that they're going to
try to stop the run especially based off
what we did against arizona
and um so we just got to do our job i'm
excited to see what we're going to be
able to do against a different opponent
you had that mvp season in 2012 and that
was preceded by the knee injury on
christmas eve 2011
at your new home stadium how weird is it
to have your home games played in that
place where it had to be at that it was
clearly the low point of your career at
that point to have that knee injury
followed by your best season ever how
strange is it to be playing your home
games there
um
you know i really don't trust i don't
think about it as much you know like
you know actually in that preseason game
i didn't even cross my mind
you know so
um you know it it it happened and it was
actually a defining moment for me
because it was in that visitors locker
room
where you know i sit there i sat there
and i laid there and said to myself that
hey i'm gonna come back and i'm gonna be
better than i was before you know that's
when i had shifted my mind accepted it
for what it was
and you know
all my energy energy and my mindset
at that moment was like okay
it is what it is
when can i have my surgery you know like
moving forward making plans had already
set
started making plans on coming back and
being better than i was before so
uh it was actually a a a great moment
for me in a moment that i always
remember
um so you know to be here and playing
and playing in the same stadium um you
know
it's crazy how things kind of come
around full circle
and you've still got that very positive
outlook that that very strong sense of
belief in yourself was there any point
this year where you thought the call
wasn't going to come or did you know in
your heart you know what somebody's
going to get hurt at some point they're
going to give me a chance and i'm just
going to make the most of it when i get
it
yeah you know early on you know i uh you
know thought the call would come earlier
you know just kind of looking around and
looking at some depth charts and stuff
and seeing what what was available i
mean what guys had
um but you know as it kind of got later
and training camp started you know just
like well you know um i guess it is
going to be that situation you know that
you know someone's going to get hurt and
then they'll need to bring someone in
you know so
it was unfortunate uh and then of course
it was a roller coaster you know when
you're talking about the the emotions
and stuff like that and going through it
and different thoughts that cross your
mind
and um you know for me to sit here and
say that
i thought well i guess i won't be
playing uh
yeah you know it it might have crossed
my mind
you know because i knew that i could
control
you know an organization or you know a
gm or a head coach as far as you know
bringing me in
but you know when i thought came i
immediately erased it you know i
counseled that thought
um as soon as possible and always kind
of reverted back to you know what
unfortunately you know this is the game
of football you know injuries happen
things happen you know something to come
up you know something to come up or you
know that was the second scenario the
first scenario was you know what um you
know the season
gets started here in the preseason
and you know teams won't be
as satisfied with their run game and
then they'll go
out and try to bring someone in you know
and then i'll get the call you know so
you know unfortunately it was b you know
someone went down with it with an injury
and the opportunity presented itself
you passed a couple of all-time greats
this weekend marshall faulk and jim
brown have you heard from either of them
uh no i haven't i haven't heard from
them um but i already know it's all love
you know jim brown is a guy that you
know i've talked to in the past several
times and you know every time i see him
him and his wife you know they're always
you know shout showering me with love
and and my and giving me support and
stuff like that um and then you know
marcia faulk too you know he's he's a
good guy that i've always had love for
and shows me a lot of respect so
um you know i'm sure it'll come
eventually but there's no pressure
another hall of famer had something to
say before the season started his name's
chris carter he said adrian had better
get over himself we were all great but
at the end we all smelled like a baby's
diaper have you reached out to him to
say have you ever smelled a baby's
diaper that smells so sweet
no i haven't you know i haven't you know
i don't know what it is with him but
you know um
you know what do you
think i i don't know
to be honest with you i i don't know
i have no clue like i can't pinpoint
and and put my hand on one thing you
know like we play different positions
and i don't know maybe because i
got more career you know yards than him
from minnesota i don't i don't know what
it is i haven't wrapped my mind around
it but
at the end of the day you know he's he's
one person
you know and
you know i just try to block him out and
just you know whatever it is what it is
it was just more personal because
he
he actually played for the vikings for a
long time
um and
through a lot of the situations i've
been to been through that he commented
on he could have reached out and got
some intel you know that's not known to
public to you know to base his opinion
on and not just go
um off of uh the face value of things
that he was hearing and seeing
um so it was just that it was more so
out of respect like hey you know um
you know like for instance daryl green
called me last sunday you know i had his
number and i was gonna call him to talk
to him about the number but guess what
i haven't been here three weeks and he
got my number and called me on sunday so
it's like if you know if you wanted to
reach me for anything
you you can do that you know but you
decide just to go on your own merit
and um you know come up with your own
conclusions to different things and make
all these foul comments about me you
know and you know i don't know i'm not
really into breaking and trying to break
people down and beat people down you
know with negative talks um you know but
you have some people that are like that
and you and you just gotta continue to
press forward no matter what the
naysayers uh have to say about you
i saw you did a game for fox last
weekend if he ends up doing one of your
games are you gonna give him a little
little tighter handshake squeeze than
you normally do
oh yeah i'm definitely trying to
question him
i don't think you have to try i i don't
i'm never shaking your hand adrian but i
don't think you have to try i'm afraid
of what you would do if you would
actually try to crush someone's hand
well i'm going to try this out
[Laughter]
all right
you you and your wife ashley have a
foundation you have an auction coming up
tell us what we need to know about that
yes the um a pearson foundation
and uh me and my wife found this um
last year and
we're just giving back to our community
you know and
giving these kids the opportunity to
experience a lot of things that we run
we weren't able to experience when we
were younger
um you know for instance we had our kids
we had our kids this summer you know
they were able to participate
in the robotic competition that took
place at the toyota
toyota center down in houston
and it was just a great opportunity for
those kids for our kids to get in there
and see
how these kids are you know just
remarkable when it comes to the
different ideals and building these
robots and not only just building the
robots
but you know what they're capable of
doing you know lifting things like
really creating missions you know so
just these engineers
and giving back to the inner city um as
well um but
on friday i am auctioning off
um and the auction starts at eight i
wanna it's from eight to twelve
and i'm watching off my 100th
shoe um
i
got some shoes made
this weekend just in anticipation of
getting a hundred yards and i mean a
hundred touchdowns and um they painted
them up there on my uh social media on
my instagram you can be able to check
them out there
um but yeah we're to auction them off
and all the funds go towards our
foundation um so we're able to continue
our mission you know to improve equality
through resources
economic uh development
and you know just transform our
community just to just to give that
empowerment that our youth need
yeah folks can check out the a a
peterson family foundation.org and it's
a great cause and i also see you're
already taking care of your offensive
lineman most guys wait until the end of
the season you're going after one week
what do you have in line for the guys
who are blocking for you
yeah i'm gonna get these guys from some
mattress you know some accessories so i
want to make sure that they're sleeping
in comfort
and uh you know
they're well well rested you know so i'm
gonna get those guys set up with king
size matches
and um yeah just go from there
hey adrian before i let you go and i
really appreciate you taking the time
when you have a little time off i know
it's a busy season for you
you made a comment last week about still
having a goal of catching emmett smith
and and and there's a lot of yards still
there but i i remember when i saw that i
thought hey i'm never betting against
adrian peterson at anything you put your
mind to something and you got a chance
of doing it i know you had a couple lost
seasons there but uh do you i mean
how are you i know it's great to have
goals how realistic do you believe that
goal is
i feel like it's realistic you you know
very realistic uh realistic
in the great words of kevin garnett
anything is possible
you know so that's how i deal with it
you know i'm able to continue to you
know to
have success and you know
uh you know stay injury free you know
and play you know three to four more
years
and i definitely can see my i definitely
see myself
um claiming that title you know and
and in order to achieve something you
have to believe it you know so
um you know i'm i'm a believer
well hey and i've always been a believer
i remember seeing a rookie in his first
game take a swing pass 60 yards against
the falcons and i don't think they knew
what the hell hit them that game and
you're still doing it all these years
later it's great to watch adrian
congratulations on what you've
accomplished and we look forward to
seeing how the rest of the story unfolds
all right i appreciate it man thank you
so much
you